[Music]
it's been 15 years since the fall the
city is a corpse and we are the worms
we burrow in it fighting for every
useful piece of land to preserve
ourselves from the terrors of the night
and the horrors of the day
who can hear my voice I shall therefore
speak a word up to here
anyone who dares to steal food will be
hanged and their body will be exposed
every day we rise from dust to choose
between bad and worse
[Applause]
these choices we take to survive will
create the world to come
you know literally get to the nearest
safe house and wait until dawn good
night and good luck
you
[Music]
sunlight two features a functioning
ecosystem it reacts on multiple levels
to the things you do and the choices you
make in the example we're about to show
you our protagonist undertakes a mission
for the peacekeepers one of the many
factions after to the city they want you
to negotiate with two survivors who are
controlling and hoarding a water supply
you're going to insult this with another
final offer let's say you choose to
carry out the peacekeepers orders one
way or another
after this you'll start seeing a
significant change in the city as access
to the water supply is allowed the
peacekeepers to bring stability and
develop the air
there's even running water for the
people at street level
and that raises their morale and allows
you to replenish your energy on the go
but there's a cost to this
the PKS of our rigid approach to law and
order
so while the streets may be safer it's
only safe for those who side with them
if you get on their bad side
now let's return to that moment of
choice and instead of killing them you
choose to team up with this group to
supply water and black market as you
will see this creates a very different
set of consequences for the city with
water being a precious currency that
brings you access to new resources and
trade
but this in turn attracts the worst type
of people to the area and this is just a
single decision one out of hundreds
you'll have to make
but it allows you to carve out your own
world your own city from the apocalypse
each player's game experience will be
unique and by the way this is just what
happens in the day at night well things
tend to get a lot darker
[Music]
you
you